camille dante et noailles camino ca fait
camino allant d'âge promeneurs il n'y a
pas de chemin on fait son chemin en
marchant promener un appartement il fait
sommaire marsan au poète antonio machado
ton chemin amené à l'exil mettez verts
font écho ici à la réunion quelques
millions d'années du feu de l'eau et du
vent ont façonné tant qu'acteur était
habitants ont usé était contré chemins
sentiers rues routes impasse
mais tel le chemin que tu as pris chacun
d'entre nous suit le sien
[Musique]
doit-elle passer par ici
ou par
là à l'obstacle et gras la route est
dangereuse
et cette voix n'existent pas personne ne
pense qu'elle peut exister
encore un effort
[Musique]
ça y est
la voie est ouverte
il est plus facile de suivre la voie
d'un autre il faut se mesurer à l'autre
mais aussi à soi
mais chaque voix est unique
[Musique]
elle n'appartient qu'à soi
tout ça vivre on lui a dit qu'il n'ya
qu'un chemin qu'un vainqueur il est né
vainqueur mange et respire vainqueur il
doit écraser l'autre écrasé celui qui
n'est pas lui
hélas
la chute
quelle douleur il doit se relever
montrez-lui un miroir qu'il crache sur
cet homme on se croise parfois sur cette
longue route
ça va
ça vient
tu es le cours de l'eau avec ou sans ces
obstacles tout se poursuit finir ses
études trouver un travail trouver
l'amour le désir d'aller vers le haut
ou peut-être pas
perdus
seuls
affligé
triste
irrité
enragé
furieuse mais une main tendue un mode où
ça vous change parfois la vie
[Musique]
tu es magnifique je t'aime je t'aime je
serai toujours là pour toi tu es mon ami
je t'aime je crois en toi je suis fier
de tours j'ai confiance en toi
tu es plus jeune et naïf il se repose
dans le vert il cherche un ami
[Musique]
mais il va apprendre que dans ce monde
toutes les attentions ne sont pas bonnes
tu es le vilain petit le droit tu feras
ce que gti de fait que matra bien à dire
tu le vilain petit canard suivez le
droit chemin ordre franchement les gens
comme toi c'est pour votre bien à ce que
je t'ai dit de faire tu dois pas tous
modes tuer le vilain petit canard
franchement les gens souvent été dit de
faire jeudi soir deux mois elle suivait
va très bien et si elle rêvait d'un
monde où chacun se soucie de lui dell de
son bien-être de ses envies de ses
amours de ses combats de ses espoirs de
ses rires et de ses larmes
la certitude est toujours ensemble quand
soudain le destin les sépare elles ne
comprennent pas pourquoi elle doit se
quitter elles ne peuvent tout simplement
pas s'imaginer loin l'une de l'autre
mais le savent au plus profond d'elle
elles ne peuvent plus continuer cette
route ensemble
[Musique]
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions
le temps passe et l'expérience remplace
peu à peu la nouveauté
est là
deux promeneurs
de chemin
peut-être as-tu raison antonio
peut-être que tu as raison
[Musique]